шанований у 4 столітті просила вивчаємо та
іншого класу
розглядав особливості нальчане я вже не
вт звичайного до дування ту ж увагу
чисел із переходом через розряд
закладену програму вже історії частини
не програми прописано прийоми так та ваня
то уваги і ківи кури стає
при суспільстві не сундарі злить із переходом
через розряд
ми ж у 20 вже не пішого класу дізнаємося з
цього ж не ним-то увагою числа
частини нами тому в іншому про клас мета
прийом перенесення йому на випадки суспільстві
з переходом через розряд
то розгадаємо це еротичніше уявити
його прийому правило до давання суми до
числа давити увагу суми від числа
також чемний поспішала класу ведений
прийом до дування чисел шляхом
надання до данків адже увага
на піт стали взаємозв'язок q ревматичних
день до дування то уваги їх так само
приносимо вона випадки суспільстві не magic
з переходом через розряд новим для вже не
адже буде прийом уваги до і
ґрунтується направо леви увагу числа
вид суми після давнього формування вийшли
у прийомі fob числа не подано на слайді
за значимо ще петля за свою її хочеш
ним і складаються таблиці додавання
Таві уваги в між 20 адже бувають вже не
все способом заокруглення 3d модель
розведу методика на чані вже немає а крем
їх прийомі як числами в польшу ну класі
числа пі джі п'ятірки адже 2 до 5 вже не
до давав це ж не малої частини нами на
приклад п'є і туди чітери інший
туди ніг чітери подаємо у виглядаєш суми
двох чисел на приклад 2 і 2 до 5 до
давати йому чотири на еліт рази, а часті
нам і спочатку доп'є і до дому 2 а
потім дала держава результату до жінок ще
два в ікона йому суспільство не до 5 до дати
2 роки 7 і до 7 219
адже чотири дні ти чотири види йєнн
подаємо його виглядають суми 2 і 2 адже не
моїм 4 на вигляд разу а частина іншому
спочатку витку ти ж не маємо 2 а
потім тримай на
результат ще раз піднімаємо тільки в
іконам спільне славить 5 адже не маємо 2
буде 3 або 3 мабуть йому 21 рік і у
зажену йому спосіб мірку ваня першинг
роком абу інший та так до бази даних
подаємо виглядаєш суми двох годин до
даємо взуття дні травня moze число на або
тремчу а часті нам і спочатку дай йому
а піднімаємо а одна з числа
а потім друга за значущу magic 10 до
води мабуть ти частим і можна не одним
окей кома способами закладено with keith
кістки випадок кіфу складі числа
краще такого немає, а ж увага часта
новими ж 10 ґрунтується на знанні
складати she is in бачив до п'ят і
вміння піддаватися число виглядає суми
двох до танків
вміння цього ти ж не мотати числа
вигляд 1 до 5
заміні вчу інший до ніг взуття гнівних
суму 2 до данків
ми факт особисто та дай йому суму до числа
а ви ж не мою суму вид числа там у
всі правила та tours пічну основи прийому
про кількість нечастий нами на відьом виду
дування таві дні маня частий на ви
magic 10 підлога та інше так даних тобі
знімних ми могли заміні вати body акоїв
сумою в межах 20 моєї заміни у малюка
суму з ручних до данків та пам'ятаю че
обидва знаємо шуй вчить число до 10 тому
в мішок 20 прийом числа не джастином і
грунтується вона вміннях клана тижнів
по данину від числа у вигляду сум з
ручних до данків та підлога мене числа до 10
про зменшення числа до 10 і ваня до
10 1 цифрового числа адже увага вид
10 1 цифра го числа звучу я на тобі і
маюсь спеціальним шинам but i вид
неприємний перед тим як вейдена прийом
цього не це ж увага 16 краще на
етапі підготовки та роботи треба а хто
лізу вати склад чисел особливо склад
числа 10 років працювати доповни жодна
цифра го числа досягти
ти зменшення 2 цифрового числа іншу
десятку до 10 з чоловіком його засувом
спеціальну систему начальник завдань
завдання на духовний немає числа до 10
можна uri знамо ні ти за собою
погоню трансформованих прав
подавитися завдання чітери
вже знімаю відразу мід ще й посагу
одна цифрових число так само можна про
числі волати частини нами
али іванівни інший до даних доповнять
та до 10 завдання номер 5
аналогічно праві дні манії вивив їх
можна мабуть то частини нами али іванівни
щоб одна з його чистим змішувала два
цифрових меншого треба 10
завдання 6 при пізнанні нині їзди до ванням
частини нам із переходом через розряд
дати сильно створи ти проблемну
ситуацію
шляхом розряду веденого вже ним випад
куди давання magic 10 у минуле всієї
сумі 1 до ніг сухо йому шлях і
розв'язування проблемних ситуацій за
допомогою науковості настрибнути нам їсть
інок чакру шків викладаємо на ми стінки
означає на карту з числом мама до дати
то ми приїдемо ще 2 нам і стінки ями
зазвучати давала число 22 з 11 таммуз
початку до будинку 1 а потім сіоди до 9
приємну йому один одержима 10 заміні розуму
10 про креми нам і верстат у колишньому
десятку і вишилася а до 10 ще приємно
ти одну нам і стінку одне а дев'ятьма
одержимому 11
чим можна світ кого ти так сам ще року 8
до дати 3 год і ключем давай найнятий
ідеї
ключем я доповнення 8 до 10 тому інший
дуданів 3 треба по дати у вигляди сум
з ручних до Данки
2 і 1 і давай сенс вчать куди дату 2 а
потім до отриманого результату і так тягни
один важливий ледве зупинений 10 і до 10 до
дати один одержима
12 аналогічно створі йому проблемну
ситуацію побачивши ниві увагу
джастином та з переходом через розряд
розгадаємо відомий ученим випадок на
приклад вид 10 одним а йому чітери
блискуче у володі таємниця тичу і об'ємних
4 можна замінити
суму їм кілька способів і шляхів
ЗМІ ми знаємо шева ногу з твоєму проблему
ситуацію чим можна так само верхи вати
привернути увагу числа чітери вигляд 12
адже 20 легко чи можна дня ти його
приділіть число 2, а потім десяток треба
розтруби цієї води нитки та бачать ще два
від того ж ключі нду розрізання я зменшення
два цифрові числа одному в десятку до 10
дали мишу не аналізу і тпа слідів скрізь
звик вона не так та ваня то ж
уваги чисел часті нам і у завальний у
цих і формулу йому пам'ятку по дону
слайді на етапі 1 нова закріплення всієї
коло і позначки пробавляються вже ним і
волосся і фіксуються в розпал потрібному
записи на перших етапах за свій не
пропаду йому очному випадки про число
нечастий нам і без переходу через розряд
та з переходом через розряд
осп ставши і не